[Musik]
ein schweizer staatsbürger sitzt in
thailand im gefängnis er wurde zu
dreieinhalb jahren haft verurteilt weil
er versucht hat seine ehemaligen
arbeitgeber zu erpressen die in den
größten finanzskandal unserer zeit
verwickelt sind durch seine beschwerden
hat javier der welt den sensationellen
diebstahl von mehreren milliarden
franken offenbart es ist die
unglaubliche geschichte die zum
unrühmlichen ende der bank der
italienischen schweiz führt doch xavi
ist der einzige der dafür bezahlen muss
[Musik]
malaysische schatten von philip lau und
alters und 4
[Musik]
miami dts project cars 24 mai 2016 der
fall explodiert die bsi hat die
gesetzlichen bestimmungen zur geldwäsche
schwer verletzt mit diesem harten urteil
kündigt die schweizer aufsichtsbehörde
finma eine noch nie dagewesene maßnahme
an die bsi muss verschwinden ein
erdbeben auf dem tessiner finanzplatz
doch der große skandal erstreckt sich
über vier kontinente
insgesamt sind 3 bis 4 milliarden
franken verschwunden buchstäblich
gestohlen sagen ermittler in
verschiedenen ländern geldwäsche
korruption und ein riesiges schwarzes
loch das die älteste bank des kantons
tessin verschlingen wird
[Musik]
als ich thailand verließ war das essen
im gefängnis knapp es gab trotz der
schrecklichen hitze keine ventilatoren
sogar das wasser war begrenzt zeitungen
waren verboten und es gab keine
möglichkeit mit der außenwelt zu
kommunizieren
wir gehen in ihrem haus in genf ist
laura seit monaten in einen schwierigen
und nicht ungefährlichen kampf
verwickelt um die freilassung ihres
mannes zu erreichen recherchiert sie
sammelt beweise und meldet den fall den
schweizer behörden lauras kämpft gegen
die fragwürdige justiz eines fernen
landes aber vor allem gegen mächtige
leute die daran interessiert sind
klavier hinter gittern zu lassen
wenn man all das geld das gestohlen
wurde und all die millionen die sie
haben dann versteht man auch die
entschlossenheit mit der sie versuchen
ihre taten zu verbergen und da raus zu
kommen sind sie bereit alles zu tun
[Musik]
sara und laura sind nur ein teil der
geschichte die immer wieder die bsi
streift aber wie sind sie in diese
geschichte hineingeraten es ist
unvermeidlich mit ihm anzufangen mit
najib razak dem autoritären
premierminister von malaysia im jahr
2009 richtete er den erster manager
development board fonds kurz one before
mit mehreren milliarden dollar ein um
die wirtschaftliche entwicklung des
landes zu fördern er betreut den
gewieften spross einer wohlhabenden
malaysischen familie und freund des
stiefsohns des premierministers mit der
leitung des unternehmens das ist er solo
der regisseur des großen betrugs der
beginnt in genf an den ufern des
genfersees arbeitet ein weiterer
protagonist der geschichte
tarik oberried ein schweizer saudischer
herkunft der sich mit dem inhaber einer
finanzberatungsfirma anfreundet xavi
mein mann stammt tarik damals sehr nah
er hatte eine besondere zuneigung
als ich meinen mann kennenlernte hatte
tarik kein geld es war klar jeder ihm er
bot ihm an sich in seiner firma fingern
vor einzurichten so konnte tarik
oberried einen büro haben und es gab ihm
auch eine gewisse glaubwürdigkeit für
die firma die er gerade gegründet hat
eröffnete in genf die petro saudi eine
kleine ölgesellschaft große ambitionen
leere kassen später ein büro in london
in der zwischenzeit haben laurant xavi
einen traum sie wollen sich in thailand
ein neues leben aufbauen sie brechen
2008 auf es ist eine sehr glückliche
zeit heirat geburt eines kindes ein
touristisches vorhaben doch da erwacht
ihr freund tarek wieder zum leben
die welt daran erinnere ich mich
auf meinen mann mehrmals an und zuerst
sagt er er wolle nicht sein angestellter
werden da war sein job angebot und das
meines mannes war sehr verlockend sogar
unglaublich in bezug auf gehalt und boni
und auch für das niveau des neuen
geschäfts direkt berate mehrere wochen
lang darauf ist klar wem ich fragte was
hältst du davon ich sagte ihm nach
thailand können wir immer noch warum
gehen wir also nicht nach london
probieren es dort wir können jederzeit
nach thailand zurückkehren warum also
nicht diese chance nutzen
[Musik]
london ist eine weitere obligatorische
station auf unserer suche wir kommen an
einem tag dort an in dem die britische
presse immer noch über den von mdb
skandal spricht in der britischen
hauptstadt treffen wir auf eine weitere
schlüsselfigur unserer geschichte sie
lebt unter polizeischutz
mehrmals haben hacker ihren computer
gehackt und malaysia hat sie offiziell
als staatsfeind bezeichnet
die journalistin claire russell brown
wurde in malaysia geboren seit jahren
prangert sie die korruption in dem
asiatischen land an in dem der
durchschnittslohn nur 300 dollar pro
monat beträgt claire gründete den
sarawak report dessen inhalt uns dabei
leiten wird den betrug und die
verwicklung der bsi darin genau zu
verstehen
während seines gesamten korrupten
politischen lebens hat premierminister
najib ein paar dinge verstanden
den ton angibt er hat verstanden dass
alles seinen preis hat man muss eine
riesige menge geld anhäufen damit man
malaysia kontrollieren kann man kann
alles kaufen was man will propaganda ein
gutes image von sich selbst wirklich
alles er hat viel in persönliche
beziehungen investiert sie das geld von
one mdb wurde dafür verwendet er hat
riesige beträge aus den öffentlichen
fonds auf seine privatkonten überwiesen
er zeigt uns bilder eines entscheidenden
tages september 2009 eine gruppe von
freunden mit dem malaysischen
premierminister najib auf einer yacht an
der côte d'azur so erlaubten aber nicht
wirklich
bei der party dabei eigentlich hatte er
alles arrangiert hier ist tarik obama
nach genf und von petrus audi das sind
die tochter und der sohn von posma und
magie es ist ein sehr kleiner kreis aber
alle akteure sind da alle
ein entscheidendes spiel welche gespielt
und das treffen wurde organisiert um ein
joint venture zwischen von mtv und pedro
saudi zu unterzeichnen in ein paar
stunden ist das geschäft unter dach und
fach sie haben es alle eilig aus dem
malaysischen fonds sollen so schnell wie
möglich mehr als eine milliarde dollar
an petrus audi überwiesen werden dass
sich von einer leeren kiste in einem see
voller geld verwandelt mit an bord ist
auch der junge prinz turki sechster sohn
des königs von saudi arabien ein neuer
teilhaber von petrus audi er bringt
seinen prestigeträchtigen familiennamen
mit an bord und zusammen mit seinen
komplizen wird der millionenschwere
provisionen kassieren
über nord die diese jungen männer wollen
den premierminister weismachen dass es
ein großes unternehmen gibt und dass man
investieren kann von einer milliarde
kassieren sie 300 millionen
aber wie man sollte wissen was mit den
anderen sieben jeder millionen oder so
passieren und das war der deal ist
ungefähr 700 millionen werden auf das
persönliche konto des malaysischen
premierminister gehen noch vor der küste
von monte carlo nimmt jolo kontakt mit
der bsi in genf auf wie aus der von
claire gefundenen e mail hervorgeht
würden sie mir bitte dringend die bsi
daten schicken der kunde muss die
überweisung der gelder veranlassen es
werden und so planen sie bereits am
abend des 28
september die überweisung der mittel an
der bsi
aber der weg nach genf ist versperrt
die ski der operation die bse tochter
will die risiken der operation
überprüfen erhält aber nicht alle
erforderlichen unterlagen einer ihrer
leitenden angestellten der anonym
bleiben möchte erzählt uns wie es zu der
entscheidung kam solo abzulehnen
wie kommt es dass ihr leute von rbs in
genf eine so gewaltige transaktion über
eine milliarde dollar ablehnt
es war eine entscheidung die in unserem
team greift wach und unter diesen
umständen waren wir nicht gezwungen die
zentrale in lugano zu informieren
letztendlich war uns nicht klar woher
die summe kam und wofür sie bestimmt war
so allen tier war das der einzige grund
nun es gab noch mehr sie erzählten uns
zum beispiel dass sie in zentralasien
ein großes stück land gekauft hätten das
reich an öl sei sie haben uns sogar ein
geladenes zu besichtigen ich ging mit
einigen kollegen dorthin ich stand vor
einem feld auf dem es nur schafe gab
aber ich versichere ihnen dass es nicht
einmal eine spur von öl dort gehabt ich
meine das war überhaupt nicht
überzeugend
wir haben gehört dass sie auch xavier
musste ihren mandanten der petrus audi
gut kannte um rat gefragt haben und auch
er hat ihnen geraten es sein zu lassen
ich will ihnen nur sagen dass in genf
nicht nur eine führungskraft die
entscheidung traf diese wichtige einlage
abzulehnen das gesamte management team
war beteiligt und stimmte dagegen
aber wie erklären sie sich dass die
milliarden einlage die sie abgelehnt
hatten später über die niederlassung in
singapur wieder bei der bsi in lugano
auftaucht
ich weiß es nicht jedenfalls entsprachen
die modalitäten der bse in singapur
nicht unserer philosophie unserer hand
sagt zwar entschieden vorsichtiger ich
würde fast sagen konservativ in asien
ist das anders man riskiert mehr und
erwartet eine höhere rentabilität
konkret
nehmen wir das bonus beispiel für
mittlere führungskräfte werden in der
schweiz etwa zwei zusätzliche gehälter
pro jahr zahlt
können es zehnmal so viele verstehen sie
wie es ihnen gefällt sich also strikt an
die vorschriften zur bekämpfung von
geldwäsche aber solo gibt nicht auf er
muss eine lösung finden er wendet sich
an die kuh zwar gegen zürich wo er einen
hochrangigen manager kennt hans peter
brunner schweizer topmanager der als der
beste für die suche nach asiatischen
kunden gilt es ist die zeit in der die
bsi beschließt sich auf asien zu
konzentrieren um einem starken rückgang
der rentabilität entgegenzuwirken
singapur wird die operative basis von
der aus der neustart erfolgen soll und
in lugano wurde beschlossen hans peter
bronner für die leitung des projekts zu
gewinnen
und ihnen die etwa 100 mitarbeiter von
kues folgen ihm ein großer transfer
ungewöhnlichen der bankenwelt eine
bestätigung für sein charisma
brunetta wird ihm brunner verschwendet
keine zeit und öffnet die türen der bse
für die gelder seines freundes solo
[Musik]
london seit dem frühjahr 2010 arbeitet
xavi bei petrus audi er hatte nicht
sofort zugang zu allen akten aber nach
und nach versteht das große geldsummen
durch pedro saudi geflossen und
verschwunden sind
je mehr er dort arbeitete je mehr
dokumente er einsehen konnte desto mehr
wurde ihnen das ausmaß des geschäfts und
der geschehnisse klar wir reden hier
nicht über ein paar zehntausend franken
sondern über millionen milliarden ich
erinnere mich an den tag an dem er zu
mir sagte es dir klar wie viel sie
gestohlen haben
was sie am meisten ärgert ist die
tatsache dass petrus audi die
abmachungen nicht einhält er erhält oft
kein gehalt keinen bonus er zahlt die
15000 franken miete pro monat die das
unternehmen zahlen sollte aus eigener
tasche außerdem sagt er laura habe das
geld seinen ehemaligen freund arek stark
verändert
er lud uns zu einer weinprobe ein die
10.000 euro pro person kostet aber sie
ging nur fünf minuten takt beschloss
sofort zu gehen weil er sich langweilt
40 bis 50.000 euro in ein paar minuten
auszugeben war kein problem
hierdurch soll die tücken des geldes ist
tarek zu einem menschen geworden wer
sich für den könig der welt hält wer
glaubt er könne jeden wie einem niemand
machen
ich habe ihn selbst einmal im restaurant
gesehen
nimmt die leute so
der könig der welt hat ein zunehmend
schwieriges verhältnis zu xavi er
kritisiert ihn in der öffentlichkeit
spricht schlecht über seine freunde hast
seine tattoos nennt ihn einen user einen
verlierer 2013 verärgert beschließen die
schweizer zurückzutreten und er verlangt
was ihm zusteht millionen an rückständen
firma ich warte auf die heutige
bestätigung über das ende unserer
partnerschaft also verlasse ich das büro
und warte darauf dass du mir sagst
wieder mit meiner abfindung verfahren
wird herzlichst das hat mein mann tareq
geschrieben darauf antwortet du
arschloch es ist schön eine große klappe
zu haben aber jetzt reicht ein wort von
dir darüber und es ist aus mit uns
es ist vorbei das ist das ende es ist
nicht nur das ende ihrer beziehung nein
ich denke vielmehr
zu diesem zeitpunkt sie pedro saudi xavi
als problem es kommt zur konfrontation
und die schweizer finden er müsse sich
schützen
sie sich vor den drohungen von tarek zu
schützen bietet mein mann um eine kopie
des servers von pedro saudi
[Musik]
hielt daraufhin tausende sensibler daten
jetzt könnt ihr alle geheimnisse des
geschäfts mit one only be er versucht
das zu bekommen was ihm zusteht zunächst
verspricht dem petrus audi eine
abfindung von sechs millionen dollar
doch daraus werden vier als der vertrag
unterzeichnet ist servier gibt sich
nicht zufrieden
er will die fehlenden zwei millionen und
zusammen mit laura beschließt er nach
thailand zurück zu kehren doch eine
kopie der daten von petrus audi bleibt
in einem bankschließfach der bse in genf
versteckt
coulibaly sieht einige malaysia kamen
nach london und natürlich fragte ich sie
ob sie irgendwelche neuigkeiten über ron
mdb sie antworteten in der tat ja jemand
versucht an einige oppositionelle
heranzukommen und die hätten einige
interessante daten sehen sie wir haben
welche schauen sie sich an ich hatte
mich eingehend mit dem fall befasst und
konnte erkennen ob die dokumente echt
waren die die mir vorlagen waren zu
genau um falsch zu sein über die
malaysia sagten zu mir er verlangt eine
menge geld
ein mann hatte große angst sie zu
treffen der könnte claire nicht der er
hätte sagen sollen sehen sie das sind
sehr gefährliche leute die viel einfluss
und viel geld haben und vor allem viele
gute kontakte
ich weiß dass tarek meinen mann nach
thailand hat verfolgen lassen den hat
von einer spionage firma
telefonaufzeichnungen von klavier
erhalten
er hatte seine telefonaufzeichnungen er
wusste alles wer ihn angerufen hat und
wann
hast du bewegt sich sehr vorsichtig aber
jetzt hat er beschlossen sein herz
auszuschütten
über einen mittelsmann gelingt es klärt
den schweizer zu kontaktieren sie machte
einen termin aus das erste treffen
findet in einem hotel in bangkok stadt
nun albergo die bangkok
sicher ich war ziemlich nervös ich war
den ganzen weg nach bangkok geflogen
eine einzelne frau die sich mit einem
fremden treffen wollte die man sagte mir
sogar er könnte mit der mafia in
verbindung stehen
dann taucht hinter mir dieser große
große muskulöse kerl auf ich dachte er
könnte mich umbringen aber er war sofort
sehr höflich
er sagte ich will zwei millionen dollar
und ich sagte wissen sie ich habe noch
nie in meinem leben für eine story
bezahlt ich bin nur eine journalistin
und ich habe keine zwei millionen also
muss ich sie davon überzeugen mir die
infos zu geben er sagte mir auch etwas
was ich jetzt dass er verstehe die hatte
nämlich dass er eine finanzielle
absicherung brauche ich weiß noch wie er
zu mir sagte du hast das mit mächtigen
leuten zu tun wer diese leute leben in
einer anderen welt sie können mit jedem
machen was sie wollen und sie kommen
damit durch
ich war wirklich entschlossen diese
geschichte zu bekommen so etwas passiert
selten
jedenfalls zeigte er mir die dokumente
tausende von daten die beweise für einen
riesigen betrug
über 250.000 e mails findet sich die
ganze geschichte
die journalistin ist auf der suche nach
jemandem der die nachfrage der schweizer
befriedigen kann und sie findet ihn es
ist toll ein malaysischer verlags magnat
der der opposition nahesteht januar 2015
in singapur findet das entscheidende
treffen statt der verleger beruhigt xavi
er wird ihm die zwei millionen dollar
zahlen
ein händedruck und clavier sagte sie
sind ein gentleman und ich habe die
festplatten bei mir aber dann hat der
verlag chemie bezahlt ich glaube tom
wollte ihn wirklich bezahlen aber in
malaysia kann man heute für straftaten
belangt werden die ist gestern noch gar
nicht gab und der verleger könnte so
plötzlich für alles verantwortlich
gemacht werden die angst davor hielt ihn
davon ab selbst als er die angriffe
sabine nicht ausgesetzt waren
frühling 2015 mit den ersten artikeln
von klär explodierte skandal ihre
enthüllungen alarmieren petrus audi die
am ende 1,8 milliarden von mdb erhalten
zu haben scheint der kronzeuge xavi muss
zum schweigen gebracht werden
es war alles sehr hart ein dutzend
polizisten kam herein durchsuchte unser
haus beschlagnahmte alle unsere computer
alle unsere tablets alle unsere telefone
sie steckten in einen tag lang in eine
zelle ohren flogen sie ihn in die
hauptstadt
24 stunden später saß er in einem
gefängnis in bangkok
[Musik]
juni 2015 xavi ist verhaftet worden
angezeigt wegen versuchter erpressung
seine haftbedingungen sind schlecht und
sein thailändischer verteidiger ein
dilettant
patrick maroni und tarik hatten alles
geplant um einen mann einem der
schlimmsten verbrecher einem
gefährlichen kriminellen auszuliefern
sie haben es im thailändischen
malaysischen und singapurischen
fernsehen gezeigt
wie kamen die presse mit ins spiel sie
konnten sie so schnell von malaysia nach
thailand reisen lassen sie wirklich die
zeit ein flugzeug zu erwischen nein
alles war von anfang an geplant
duplikat und der beweis dafür ist dass
sie bereits dort waren als clavier
festgenommen wurde
laura laura hat keine zweifel daran dass
die führer von petrus audi bestochen
worden waren der bangkok hat mussawi
hinter sich lassen
gleich nach der verhaftung erhielt ich
einen anruf von seinem anwalt der anwalt
hielt den hörer in der hand und ich
konnte meinen mann aus der zelle
schreien hören und er schrie ich bin
verhaftet worden aber keine sorge ich
habe einen anwalt und von diesem moment
an war es ein abstieg in die hölle
es stellt sich heraus dass hinter dem
betrug mehr steckt als nur petrus audi
zwei weitere operationen dieser art sind
bereits in die wege geleitet worden
milliarden ströme der malaysische
premierminister najib wird zugeben dass
er fast 700 millionen erhalten hat aber
er wird eine wenig glaubhafte erklärung
dafür abgeben es handele sich um ein
geschenk von saudi arabien das teilweise
zurückgezahlt wurde gut dieser artikel
stammt noch aus der anfangszeit als ich
die richtigen informationen bekam und
der fall der bank der italienischen
schweiz eröffnet wurde ich habe diese
ersten dokumente gefunden aus denen
hervorging die solo geld von codes in
zürich zur bsi in singapur überwiesen
hatte das war eine riesige enthüllung
tier sollte er das erklären konnte was
wir der degussa größer
hier können sie die transaktionen der
folgenden monate sehen
diese einzahlung ging von kurz in zürich
zur bsi in singapur mit sieben
aufeinanderfolgenden transaktionen
seit juni 2011 hat er 528 millionen
dollar der oft genannten 700 millionen
überwiesen soll das ist das gestohlene
geld
[Musik]
kaum 30 jahre alt genießt solo das gute
leben in vollen zügen von amerika bis
europa macht er sich mit seinen party
seinen namen der nikki beach im centro p
ist ein club für privilegierte die
berühmte erbin paris hilton gehört zu
den stammgästen hier fließt der teuerste
champagner 50.000 euro pro flasche und
auch der freundschaft rabatt ist
exzessiv so kosten die getränke zusammen
nur
107.000 euro aber jolo kümmert sich auch
um seine eigenen angelegenheiten er
investiert viel geld in den usa wie das
us justizministerium bestätigt etwa 300
millionen in immobilien plattenfirmen
hotels luxus flugzeuge und sogar diese
mini der für 57 einheit millionen dollar
gekauft wurde alles so die ermittler mit
dem geld das aus dem babyphon gestohlen
wurde und oft via überweisung von der
bsi eine kolossale geldwäsche operation
und dann wäre da noch hollywood
stiefsohn des malaysischen
premierministers erhält von solo den
auftrag zur gründung einer
filmproduktionsgesellschaft und
finanziert den film the wall street mit
leonardo dicaprio in der hauptrolle
es ist eine film denunziation über
drogen sport und die unfassbare gier die
in der finanzwelt herrscht es klingt wie
ein witz wenn man bedenkt was solo in
der bsi macht
[Musik]
ovi store alister del sol gabetta alaba
singapur ich habe die liste seiner
unternehmen gesehen wie er bei der bse
ihren singapur eröffnet hatte dutzende
von ihnen wieder eröffnete sogar sechs
auf einmal wenn die bsi einen kunden
hätte sehr unendlich viele firmen
eröffnet nun und in vielen von ihnen gab
es nichts nun mutig sicherlich hätte die
bank die möglichkeiten diese
auffälligkeiten zu erkennen und zu sehen
dass laufen transaktionen über die bsi
abgewickelt werden ich meine die bank
könnte sich zumindest fragen warum
lugano cordaz
was weiß man bei der obersten bsi in
lugano über solo der viele
briefkastenfirmen eröffnet es dauert
einige zeit bis die aussagen einiger
leitender angestellter von damals
zusammen getragen waren keiner war
bereit sein gesicht zu zeigen sie
behaupten dass auch die
bundesanwaltschaft ermittelt und das
bankgeheimnis eine rolle spielt auf dem
parkplatz eines europäischen flughafens
erklärte sich jedoch einer der damaligen
leitenden angestellten der bank bereit
uns zu treffen
november 2014 wusste ich nicht einmal
genau wert dieser juno war ich wusste
nur dass es diesen einen reichen kunden
gab der mann mdb in die bank eingeführt
hatte aber ich wusste dass hanspeter
born ein sehr gut kannte eines tages
zeigte mir ein kollege eine zeitung und
sagte sie mal dass der malaysische kunde
der uns von mdb gebracht hat es war ein
bild von solo mit paris hilton
also warte ich im nächsten
verwaltungsrat um einige informationen
über die
aber hatten sie denn irgendwelche
zweifel
natürlich wussten sie von den besonders
hohen provisionen die dieser betreibern
unsere bank zahlte ich musste zugeben
dass sich jemand gefragt hat warum die
provisionen zu unseren gunsten so hoch
waren und ob dahinter nicht verdächtige
wenn nicht sogar illegale dinge steckten
aus singapur erhielten wir jedoch eine
beruhigende antwort per solo ist ein
sehr reicher kunde und er hat es sicher
nicht nötig derartige transaktionen zu
tätigen
und sie waren damit einverstanden
sehen sie ich sage ihnen dass wir
bereits einen externen wirtschaftsprüfer
ernst young kontaktiert hatten und er
die operation im allgemeinen analysiert
hatte aber er war nicht näher auf das
berufliche profil von solo eingegangen
kein profil
fundamental wie ein grundlegender punkt
die bsi muss die malaysischen vor nicht
verwalten sie muss das geld nicht zum
laufen bringen sie ist nur eine
depotbank aber nur für die verwahrung
des geldes erhält sie eine provision von
2% was 40 mal mehr ist als das was
normalerweise verlangt wird der gewinner
bsi ist abnormal warum ist solo so
großzügig wille weniger kontrolle durch
die bsi
das außergewöhnliche in dem fall ich
würde sagen das außergewöhnliche in
diesem fall sind die summen um die es
geht und die tatsache dass alle personen
seines banken- seines einzelpersonen die
an dieser geldwäsche beteiligt waren
astronomische summen erhalten haben
rechtsanwalt emanuel stauffer weiß wovon
er spricht er hat sich bereit erklärt
zum ersten mal und öffentlich über die
angelegenheit zu sprechen die ihm
vertraut ist im februar 2016 wurde
stauffer von der bsi als leiter der
rechtsabteilung eingestellt doch einige
monate zuvor hatte ihn die bank in
lugano mit einer externen und
unabhängigen evaluation beauftragt auf
stoffe drang in die büros in lugano und
singapur 1 hatte zugang zu allen
dokumenten und fügte die einzelteile der
geschichte zusammen sein bericht der
auch auf dem tisch der aufsichtsbehörde
landete ist sehr ausführlich
aber wenn eine person video hundert
konten eröffnet wird dann nicht sofort
alarm geschlagen
natürlich sollte man dann alarm schlagen
aber viel eher sollte man das tun wenn
mittel ein und ausgehen
wenn man die anzahl der konten sieht die
volumina die art der transaktionen sieht
sagt man
wenn geld ein und ausgeht nachdem es
sieben konnten am tag durchlaufen hat
und zwar nicht 100.000 sondern 20
millionen und sie immer noch versuchen
dafür eine einfache begründung zu finden
finde ich dass wir da ein problem haben
die von der bank erhalten eine vergütung
war im vergleich zu dem was sie hätte
sein sollen offensichtlich überhöht
dies war wahrscheinlich der wichtigste
weckruf der hätte ertönen müssen aber
vor allem hätte er irgendwie ein
schlechtes gewissen bereiten müssen denn
die von der band gebrachte leistung
wurde so hoch vergütet
jemand sagte uns es ist ein freier markt
das könnte eine antwort sein vielleicht
ist es nicht die richtige antwort
wenn wir über risikomanagement sprechen
geht es weniger um unwissenheit sondern
vielmehr um mangelnde sorgfalt und
unterlassung aus eigenem interesse
aus eigenem interesse heraus
bequemlichkeit dass man nicht in die
tiefe schaut dass man bestimmte
situationen nicht eingehend und kritisch
überprüft
[Musik]
er musste sagen dass er es nur fürs geld
getan hat er musste sagen dass er den
inhalt der festplatte überhaupt nicht
kannte und dass claire nicht wirklich
glaubwürdig sei
und dass er einige dokumente gefälscht
habe
und zwar um petrus audi in ein gutes
licht zu rücken
im gefängnis von bangkok bricht xavier
hustet zusammen er ist dem ständigen
druck der gesamten von pedro saudi
ausgesetzt die anscheinend jeder zeit in
seine zelle eindringen können er macht
sich sorgen um seinen sohn und seine
bedrohte frau schließlich gibt danach
und unterschreibt ein falsches
geständnis im gegenzug verspricht man
ihm eine schnelle freilassung aber auch
petrus audi nimmt eine fragwürdige rolle
an
[Musik]
wolf innigem der sich bei mir meldet
zuerst benutzte er nicht einmal seinem
richtigen namen anfangen plant er sich
paul browne dann änderte er seinen namen
impuls gott er rief mich an und teilte
mir mit dass er wisse dass mein mann
noch andere dokumente andere kopien
besitze und dass er sie bei bsi in genf
versteckt hatte er forderte mich auf sie
zurück zu geben dass sie petrus audi
gehörten ich sagte ihm dass ich ihnen
nicht trauen und er fragte mich was ich
wolle ich antwortete ihm ich will meinen
mann sprechen sonst rühre ich keinen
finger
[Musik]
es war sehr schwierig xavi japanisch so
hatte ich ihn noch nie erlebt am telefon
sagte er zu mir leider bitte zu alles
was sie dir sagen du musst alles tun was
paul sagt du musst alles tun was er von
ihr verlangt ich fliehe dich an
also meldete sich häufig in bei mir und
sagte ich werde in zwei oder drei tagen
in genf sein sie müssen wir alle
informationen geben sonst wird ihr mann
hier für neun jahre ins gefängnis gehen
[Musik]
ein paar tage später betritt laura die
bsi filiale in gent sie begibt sich in
den bereich der schließfächer sie lehrt
dasjenige in dem ihr mann andere kopien
der festplatten mit den geheimnissen von
mdb und petrus audi versteckt hatte und
dass sie nun peu wenigen übergeben muss
so versichert laura ist in wirklichkeit
ein ehemaliger britischer polizist dem
petrus audi auf sie angesetzt hat der
eher wie ein schatten folgt und sie
ständig einschüchtert
[Musik]
die figur sicherlich haben sie klar wie
gesagt dass ihnen das schlimmste
passieren würde wenn er mich nicht
überzeugen könnte und ich die papiere
nicht aushändigen würde sie truppen ihn
und sie drohten mir indem sie sagten
dass mein mann bestenfalls nach malaysia
ausgeliefert werden würde ich wiederhole
bestenfalls sie drohten mir dass sie
versuchen würden ihn zu vergiften ihn zu
töten
die wochen und monate nach der
verhaftung waren die hölle die hölle
der manager von petrus audi der am
eindringlichsten versucht blaue rad zur
zusammenarbeit zu bewegen ist patrick
mahoni der direktor des unternehmens mit
mitteln die über bloße druckaufbau
hinausgehen
juni hatte in thailand alle leute
gekauft die er brauchte bis hinauf zur
spitze um javier verhaften zu lassen
aber es war nicht nur petrus audi der
hinter diesen außergewöhnlichen manövern
steckte letztere arbeitete mit dem
malaysischen regierungschef najib und
seinem umfeld zusammen maroni gab dies
in einem aufgezeichneten telefongespräch
zu und sagte hinter ihnen stehe der
große mann wie er den premierminister
des landes nennt
es ist patrick der mich anruft und über
dem premierminister sprechen
dinge getan worden sind
das ist seine position und er hat immer
noch angst davor der mann macht weiter
stress es ist seine politische karriere
die auf dem spiel steht das ist alles
woran er denkt nichts anderes vergessen
sie nicht dass wir alle in der scheiße
sitzen
da wir erst im knast du bist allein mit
deinem kind du ich habe ich noch nicht
gesehen und gesagt dass ich mir sorgen
um dich mache
aber ich setze auch in der scheiße und
viele andere sind auch in der scheiße
da ist der premierminister eines landes
der in der scheiße steckt weil er die
scheiße mit hineingezogen wurde vergiss
das nicht
ja aber nur xavi ist im gefängnis
das nicht tun müssen ich will mich nicht
wieder darüber aufregen
[Musik]
wir betreten die stadt in der alles
begann kuala lumpur die hauptstadt von
malaysia ihre modernität symbolisiert
durch die zwillingstürme konzentriert
sich auf das glitzern der finanz- und
handelszentrum ein bild das nicht die
realität des restlichen landes
widerspiegelt das um seinen aufschwung
kämpft
wir haben einen termin mit einem
ehemaligen premierminister der als vater
der teilweisen wirtschaftlichen
entwicklung des landes gilt der mann
mattia mohammad ist heute der varta
führer der opposition er spielt eine
wichtige rolle bei der enthüllung von
bahn mgb mdb die riesige villa in der
seine büros untergebracht sind wird
diskret von der polizei des regimes
überwacht martin war einer der ersten
der die verantwortung und die illegalen
gewinne des derzeitigen regierungschefs
anprangerte
ursprünglich war maria ein verbündeter
von agip heute hielt er ihn für einen
diktator der sich der korruption bedient
das gesetz in malaysia existiert heute
nicht das gesetz kann sie nicht
funktionieren der regierungschef hat die
totale kontrolle über die polizei um 10
generalstaatsanwalt ermittlungen werden
blockiert oder wenn sie durchgeführt
werden werden die ergebnisse
verheimlicht er kontrolliert alles
ich glaube dass der premierminister
versucht sich mit den einflussreichsten
leuten anzufreunden nur indem er geld
einsetzt und er denkt dass sie ihn
schützen werden wenn ihm etwas passiert
der in thailand inhaftiert ist nach was
sagen sie glauben sie dass er monatelang
im gefängnis bleiben wird vielleicht
sogar bis zur nächsten wahl
ich weiß nicht wie lange er im gefängnis
bleiben wird aber ich denke die
schweizer regierung hat jedes recht sich
zu beschweren warum ist er immer noch
ein gefangener obwohl im august
entlassen werden sollte er hat
offensichtlich eine menge informationen
und ich denke es ist die pflicht der
schweizer regierung an diese
informationen zu kommen
und glauben sie dass najib stark genug
ist thailand und die auslieferung von
klavier musste hier in malaysia zu
bitten
[Musik]
ich weiß es nicht aber er könnte es tun
kuala lumpur kooperiert nicht mit der
schweizer bundesanwaltschaft sie
verhindert jede art von interne
untersuchung und die presse wird mundtot
gemacht das ist franky gun ein mann der
premier najib da steht er ist
vorsitzender der mächtigen vereinigung
der malaysia chinesischer herkunft er
kennt mehrere parlamentsabgeordnete die
alle loyal zum premierminister stehen
vergaben will nichts von einem skandal
wissen skandal ist dass etwa kein
skandal
ich glaube nicht dass das ein skandal
ist offen gesagt premierminister najib
ist ein sehr guter mann oder ist auch
ein sehr bescheidener unser
regierungschef hat mit dieser bahn mgb
geschichte nicht zu tun
manchmal kommt so etwas vor die in so
vielen anderen ländern auch in vielen
malaysia das ein sehr freies land in dem
jeder alles sagen kann
wie die oppositionspartei aber ist ihnen
bekannt dass es auch eine offizielle us
untersuchung gibt
in der er premierminister praktisch
beschuldigt wird sich einen teil des
malaysischen fonds angeeignet zu haben
was halten sie von dieser anschuldigung
ich weiß nicht warum ich kann mir diesen
amerikanischen bericht nicht erklären
aber unsere untersuchung hat ergeben
dass nichts gefunden wurde was in
direktem zusammenhang mit unserem
premierminister steht
ein junger finanzier aus dem umfeld von
agip solo
der malaysische ja ich habe von ihm
gehört
und was halten sie von ihm
ehrlich sagen ich weiß dass er dem
premierminister nahe stehen soll aber
das glaube ich nicht sehen sie mit ihrem
jeder kann zu ihm gehen und sagen hallo
herr premierminister kann ich ein foto
mit ihnen machen das ist kein problem
dann können sie sich vielleicht etwas
mit dem foto einfallen lassen
ich würde sagen es ist jetzt an der zeit
mit dieser von mdb sache aufzuhören ich
will darüber nicht weiter sprechen
wir befinden uns vor einer baustelle des
neuen bbi ein bauprojekt zur errichtung
eines finanz centers
in kuala lumpur führt uns ein
ortsansässiger kollegin einen platz der
als symbol für den skandal steht auf
diesem gelände sollte wann mdb ein neues
finanzzentren bauen aber alles steht
seit jahren still auf fall von mdb durch
große raubüberfälle und
fehlinvestitionen schulden in höhe von
elf milliarden dollar angehäuft hat
entgegen der wirtschaftlichen
entwicklung stattdessen ist der staat
gezwungen erhebliche kürzungen bei den
sozialleistungen vorzunehmen und das
gelände wurde an die chinesen verkauft
die schweizer banken sollten eine
mitverantwortung tragen denn die banken
müssen herausfinden woher das geld kommt
sie alle kennen das problem der
geldwäsche sie sollten vorsichtig sein
aber anscheinend haben sie nicht mit der
sorgfalt gehandelt die von einer bank
erwartet wird
der premierminister hat das geld
gestoßen wenn es sich um gestohlenes
geld handelt und wir wissen was
gestohlen wurde sollte es meiner meinung
nach an die menschen der ursprünglichen
eigentümer zurückgegeben werden ich
denke nicht dass es an den
premierminister oder die derzeitige
regierung zurückgegeben werden sollte
denn sie sind an der sache beteiligte
kriminelle
[Musik]
sie verlassen malaysia mit einem gefühl
der erleichterung
das land steht auf dem letzten platz was
menschenrechte und pressefreiheit angeht
eine stunde flugzeit singapur der
stadtstaat ist heute eine finanzielle
brücke zur eroberung asiens die großen
banken der welt versuchen hier ihr glück
[Musik]
suchen zwei personen gegen die die
örtliche justiz ermittelt und die in der
bsi die wichtigsten beziehungen zu joe
hatten den schweizer hans peter bronner
direktor der bsi in singapur und jack
juti den büroleiter der für den
malaysischen vorarbeitete
was jack angeht haben wir ein foto
seines hauses nicht weit vom
stadtzentrum entfernt
das ist ja das ist es
guten morgen wir sind auf der suche nach
herrn ja ja ja ist nicht zu hause
wissen sie wann er zurückkommt ich weiß
es nicht er hat nichts gesagt vielleicht
nach dem mittagessen
nach dem mittagessen oder am nachmittag
vielleicht am späten nachmittag
später nachmittag
hier gibt es nicht zu sehen wir werden
erst später noch einmal versuchen wir
sind auch daran interessiert mit jack
für eine weitere sache dieser geschichte
zu sprechen gegen jack wird heute in
singapur ermittelt aber vor ein paar
jahren hatte alfredo gysi lange zeit die
nummer eins bei der bsi in lugano ihm
den berühmten und umstrittenen brief
geschrieben in dem er ihm für seine
hervorragenden ergebnisse dankte die
einen bonus von 19 millionen wert sein
würden
wie unser zweites ziel ist der schweizer
top manager hans peter brunner unter
seiner führung hat die bsi in singapur
in der tat hervorragende ergebnisse
erzielt eine aggressive strategie viele
neue asiatische kunden stark wachsende
leistungen ein anstieg der
mitarbeiterzahl auf 250 ich meine ein
neues eldorado für die bank in lugano
aber das eldorado bröckelt auch nach dem
journalistischen enthüllungen agenten
der mast singapurs währungsbehörde
ermitteln wochenlang in der bsi
und am ende sprechen sie von einer
eklatanten und vorsätzliche missachtung
der vorschriften durch die bank entzug
der betriebserlaubnis und schließung des
instituts in singapur
einen hans peter brunner wird derzeit
von der maas und auch von der schweizer
aufsichtsbehörde ermittelt
aber wir hatten bereits versucht ihn
über seinen anwalt zu kontaktieren hallo
guten morgen herr rechtsanwalt
mein name ist also sofia ich hoffe für
das radio und fernsehen der
italienischen schweiz an
nun ich habe mich gefragt ob sie uns
helfen könnten mit ihren klienten herrn
brunner kontakt aufzunehmen
journalisten sprechen will gibt es dafür
einen bestimmten grund
die ermittlungen sind noch im gang
daher können wir keinen kommentar
abgeben
deshalb ist es besser wenn er nicht sagt
verstehe das ist also auch ihre meinung
als anwalt
in ordnung aber im moment steht er unter
hausarrest oder keiner sich in singapur
frei bewegen
ich gebe keinen kommentar nein denn sie
haben uns gesagt dass sie ihm den pass
abgenommen haben
fragen zu stellen
versuchen wir es mit einer e mail der
ehemalige direktor der bse in singapur
antwortet freundlicherweise dass er
nicht bereit es mit der presse zu
sprechen auch weil er an das
bankgeheimnis gebunden ist
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
sie haben bereits hans peter brunner
kennengelernt aber auch in der bse
zentrale gibt es jemanden der mainz eine
bank in der bank gegründet zu haben
banca banca brunner kannte auch solo gut
ebenso wie die mitarbeiter die ihm
gefolgt waren und mit solo direkt und
illegale geschäfte gemacht hatten kann
es wirklich sein dass ihm das alles
entgangen war
das ist unser letzter versuch herrn jagd
zu erreichen wir wissen dass jack der
auf frischer tat ertappt wurde teilweise
mit der justiz kooperiert eine gewisse
verantwortung zugegeben hat und bereit
dazu wäre siebeneinhalb millionen dollar
zurückzuzahlen
[Musik]
das ist ein auto los geht's
das ist die dame von oben
und unten abend können sie uns noch
ja er ist noch nicht zu hause könnten
wir mit herrn jörg sprechen noch nicht
tut mir leid wir haben die frau oben
gesehen
hatten sie einen moment
woher kommen sie beide
aus der schweiz
der herzlich zu hause
ja ja ja ja ist nicht da aber er ist zu
hause daher ist nicht zu hause bitte
niemand wird kommen wie er bestanden
darauf sie kam zurück sie hatte mit
jemandem gesprochen als sie zurückkam
sagte sie sie sei ausgeschöpft worden
das dienstmädchen muss ihm wohl gesagt
haben dass wir tagsüber vorbeigekommen
sind schon drei mal und jetzt haben sie
auch noch das licht ausgemacht wir
bleiben bis zum abend doch das warten
lohnt sich nicht
[Musik]
es ist auch möglich dass es ein
sicherheitsproblem gibt und zwar ein so
großes dass der staatsanwalt in den
letzten tagen gesagt hat dass die zeugen
und jack gehört auch zu den zeugen
dieses ersten prozesses den abwesenheit
vernommen werden könnten also ohne dass
sie in den gerichtssaal kommen
bin weil es ein sicherheitsproblem gibt
der staatsanwalt hat das gesagt das muss
man ihm glauben
im innern hat nicht einmal in der bse in
singapur wurden interne kontrollen
eingesetzt um die illegalen manöver von
solo und seinen komplizen innerhalb der
bank aufzudecken
die schweizer aufsichtsbehörde finma ist
unzufrieden mit den anti risiko
maßnahmen die die band nach eigenen
angaben sogar verstärkt hat und fordert
sie auf mehr zu tun
wir kommen an den punkt an dem die finma
von ihnen absolute transparenz verlangt
das heißt der kunde muss alle
informationen angeben gab es absolute
transparenz
bei einigen vorgängen herrscht
transparenz aber an einem bestimmten
punkt sagten die kundenbetreuer im
wesentlichen solo dass sie für eine
bestimmte einlage nicht alle
erforderlichen informationen geben
könnten es handele sich um verträge
zwischen regierungen deshalb müsse das
staatsgeheimnis bewahrt werden
tatsächlich beschlossen wir die
beziehungen zu den malaysischen
fondsmanager zu beenden und das trotz
der bedenken des büros in singapur und
wer hat in singapur gezögert bona
im verwaltungsrat der bse in singapur
waren vertreter der muttergesellschaft
hans peter brunner war mitglied der
konzernleitung
es gab also eine sehr starke
verflechtung zwischen der b s in
singapur und der bsi ag
man kann sagen dass die grundlegenden
informationen also alles was zur
risikoeinschätzung nötig war immer mit
der muttergesellschaft geteilt wurde
wenn ich das richtig verstehe gab es
also spannungen mit brunner
ja aber das
kann ihnen nur sagen dass lugano erst in
diesem moment von den etwa 100 konnten
hervor die juno eröffnet hatte
wie auch immer ghana hat er immer die
kontrolle war für die endkontrolle
verantwortlich
ja ich meine von wem ging es ab von
beata man
ja genau ich muss allerdings sagen dass
der verifizierung prozess funktioniert
hat
das protokoll wurde eingehalten
protokoll ja und da man beobachtete die
situation weiterhin und erachtete alle
operationen von solo als regulär
aber er wusste von der hohen anzahl der
von solo eröffneten konten natürlich
wusste er es aber entschuldigen sie sie
hatten diese informationen und er hatte
sie nicht erhalten soweit ich weis hatte
er das nicht
riad ammann ehemaliger leiter der
abteilung recht und compliance
schlüsselfunktionen für interne
kontrollen anerkannter fachmann ammann
aber übermut aber ammann hatte schon mit
der amerikanischen akte einen schlechten
start mit der firma und das würde der
bsi nicht gerade weiterhelfen aber für
meetings und radpolo er traf sich
persönlich mit juno und ließ sich von
dem jungen malaysia überreden und
behauptete stets dass aufgrund der
revisionsberichte bei one mdb alles in
ordnung sei
gegen ammann läuft heute auch eine
untersuchung der film
eine der wichtigsten regeln bei der
bekämpfung der geldwäsche ist es zu
verstehen ob die transaktionen
tatsächlich einen plausiblen
wirtschaftlichen hintergrund haben die
plausibilität der
banken und die bank von ihren der lage
zu verstehen oder zu wissen wofür dieses
geld aber
war das nicht ein grund um stopp zu
sagen das war ein grund um zu sagen dass
man aufhören soll und das hat die finma
auch so empfunden nicht die bank die
band ging davon aus dass das ende 2014
dass man sie ließ sich also zeit vier
jahre nachdem die konten eröffnet wurden
in vier jahren hatte eine menge geld
angehäuft eine menge geld
was ist das für ein system das eine bank
einrichtet die alles verschwinden lässt
nun dass wir sind nicht nur knapp bei
kasse wir sind sogar ein bisschen drüber
das waren die schlussfolgerungen der
firma
kelek entwickeln welche teilen sie
sakamoto soll nun die einschlagen der
ankündigung vom 24 mai 2016 über das
ende der bsi scheint die ehemaligen
führungskräfte die sich zu wehren
versuchen zu überraschen die bank
bestreitet die art und weise und zum
teil auch den inhalt der intervention
der aufsichtsbehörde es folgen
dramatische wochen eine schwere
liquiditätskrise die flucht vieler
kunden mit einem relativen verlust von
über 10 milliarden und die
beschlagnahmung von 95 millionen wegen
vermuteter gewinne aus super provisionen
zu der letzte akt einer der
schändlichsten seiten der
finanzpolitischen korruption
es überrascht mich nicht dass der
kleinste gemeinsame nenner des gesamten
one mdb skandals sicherlich die gier war
es war geld es zwar geld das
[Musik]
auf gedeih und verderb dazu geführt hat
dass das internationale bankensystem als
ganzes bei der bekämpfung der geldwäsche
in diesem speziellen fall völlig versagt
hat
dh es ist das geld es ist die menge an
geld die jedem zur verfügung steht die
es ermöglicht hat dass ein diebstahl
dieses ausmaßes überhaupt gelingen
konnte
[Musik]
ich habe vier bis sechs stunden gewartet
und konnte meinen mann nur 20 minuten
lang sehen
er konnte nicht sprechen als ich ihm das
bild unseres sohnes zeigte konnte er
nicht sprechen es war zu schwer für ihn
er hat seinen sohn seit über einem jahr
nicht mehr gesehen
nur sechs personen haben zugang zur
zelle von xavi ganz oben auf der liste
die männer von petrus audi für laura ist
es sehr schwierig ihren mann zu treffen
alles so behauptet sie wurde
aufgezeichnet
da wir wussten dass pedrosa die alle
aufzeichnungen unsere gespräche im
gefängnis erhält
hatte ich die idee mit xavi über die
gegensprechanlage über beliebige themen
zu sprechen so dass petrus audi etwas zu
hören bekommt währenddessen würde ich
sah wie aber über alles informieren was
ich draußen tat zum beispiel über die
zusammenarbeit mit dem fbi in dem ich in
einige notizen lesen die ich in mein
notizbuch eingefügt hatte
monika so lucio nicht die einzige
möglichkeit ist vor anderen zu
verbergende standarten das notizbuch zu
nehmen und es an die scheibe zu halten
von jetzt an werde ich dir alles
erzählen was ich tue und was wir tun
müssen
die koalition ist ein preview geh ich
werde thailand in schutt und asche legen
aber wir müssen es so aussehen lassen
als ob ich dort
zunehmend kritische zustand meines
mannes und die jüngsten drohungen die
ich erhalten hatte insbesondere gegen
meinen sohn haben das fass zum
überlaufen gebracht er hatte große angst
ich noch mehr angst um mich und unseren
sohn
schrieb ihnen dass wir keine andere wahl
mehr hätten und dass die einzige
möglichkeit dem jetzt zu helfen darin
bestünde dass ich nach genf zurückkehre
und alles öffentlich machen petrus audi
verstand dass ich mit der presse
sprechen würde schickte er einen
gemeinsamen freund der in genf lebt um
ihr mitzuteilen dass er hofft dass mein
mann und ich keine vergeltungsmaßnahmen
erleiden würden wenn ich aussagen würde
[Musik]
schicke mir später fertig du triffst du
nicht zu alldem getrieben hat es der
wunsch meinen sohn in den armen seines
vaters zu sehen
mein mann ist der beste mann den ich
kenne der beste vater den ich kenne er
ist kein verbrecher im gegensatz zu dem
was petrus audi im glauben machen wollte
dann nur damit meinen sohn seinen vater
zurück bekommt und ich meine man
zurückbekommen kann eine matinee mit iq
jeden morgen sage ich mir also aufstehen
und strahlend ist der tag vorüber ist
dezember 2016 der neue könig von
thailand begnadigt 30.000 gefangenen
am zwanzigster dezember eskortieren
thailändische einheiten den kronzeugen
zur schweizer botschaft in bangkok
am 21 dezember schließt xavi hu seine
familie wieder in die arme
[Musik]